ROSE ROBINSON: My
name is Rose Robinson.
I work for Anita Borg Institute,
and our community is Systers--
S-Y-S-T-E-R-S. Systers
is a community for women
in computing.
It was started in 1987, and
we're 26 year strong this year.
And we have about 4,400
plus women across the world.
So we have a lot of women
who are various computing
disciplines.
But we're really there
just to support each other,
help each other through
careers, life challenges,
professional decisions,
just much more.
Our students
actually are Systers,
so we reach out to all of
our Systers in the community.
And our main goal is actually
to do some outreach for women.
We want women to be exposed
more in open source.
So we had about six Systers
and students this year
that started out with
just maybe 15 applicants,
but we actually had six
Systers that we're actually
in the program.
My actual role was org admin,
and I was also a mentor.
My student was Julia
Proft, and she was actually
out of Connecticut College.
She was very nervous about
entering into this program
because she felt that it
was overwhelmed for her,
and she didn't have
the Python skills.
But I have to tell you by the
end of the summer program,
she was very, very
good in Python
and delivered some awesome work.
She worked on an admin
feature, where she actually
changed some of
our user interface
for our request to
join our community.
It's very cumbersome.
So she actually did a
lot of database changes,
a lot of UI design--
fantastic job.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Google Summer
of Code this year, for me,
was my first time as a mentor.
I was a student last year, and
I was way more nervous this year
than I was last year.
But my student was amazing.
She was really smart.
And everything was
just perfect with her.
She worked on
creating some scripts
for reporting about
our mailing list,
because we have more than one.
And all of the moderators
want some statistics,
and so will our
administrator, Rose.
So we worked on that together.
Well, she did all the work.
I was just mentoring,
and it was just perfect.
ROSE ROBINSON: I think I'd love
to see Systers more engaged
in some of the projects here.
We had a couple of
Systers that were
accepted into two programs.
And it was our mission to really
get our Systers more exposed
to more open source projects.
So it was perfectly
fine for us that they
were exposed and getting
engaged with other open source
projects.
I think what we will do
next year is actually just
inform our community of
what other open source
projects there are.
We found an incredible amount
of just science projects,
humanitarian projects, a
lot of server projects,
which were really cool
because a lot of Systers
are actually into those
type of technologies.
So I think they would
be very excited to see
that for next year.
If someone wants to get
involved with Systers,
they can visit systers.org--
S-Y-S-T-E-R-S dot O-R-G.
That is actually our front
page of our communities.
We have a lot of sub
communities, as well,
that are culturally driven
as well as technology driven.
So we do have a FOS
community, entrepreneurs.
And that's one way to
actually join our Systers.
And the one engagement that
we have from a community
standpoint is just
communicating with each other
and helping each other through
a lot of the technology
challenges.
So we do have a techtalk
community, and that
helps with different
projects, things
that they're getting stuck on,
or need a little bit of help
on, or a little boost.
I've actually been a Syster
for 13 years now-- since 2000.
And I believe, if my
memory serves me correctly
that we started GSoC 2007.
And that was started by Robin
Jeffries and Jenn Redman.
So we've been part
of the GSoC community
and family for a few years now.
This is my first year
as organizational admin
as well as a mentor.
So I've been involved in Python
and a lot of other open source
projects, particularly
with Mailman as well.
So it was a learning
experience for me, as well,
but also is very gratifying.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is my
second year as part of Systers.
Last year, I was a
student with them.
That's how I met them--
through a Summer of Code.
And this year I was a mentor.
And I think being a student is
way easier than being a mentor
because you don't have any--
I mean, you just have to work.
And being a mentor, you
have to be a role model.
But that's really
cool at the same time.
So I can't wait for next year.
And we hope to get is some
very good features on next year
with the students and
just keep growing.
ROSE ROBINSON: I think what I
would love to see next year,
and hopefully we can
make this happen,
is to do some collaboration
with other projects here.
I'd love to see
Systers get involved
with some of the
science open source,
humanitarian open source
projects is always great.
A lot of educators
in our communities,
so I am so looking
forward to them
getting involved with some of
the gaming for the students,
because overall, I think we
can take away from all of this,
as well, and learn and
how we can actually
help the next generation
of Systers as well.
I'm hopeful because
I'm also a mother.
I'm a mother to a
daughter and also a son.
So I want to teach both of
them that it is very perfectly
OK to see women in our roles.
As a daughter, I want
her to actually pursue
any type of technology
that she can,
because every technology
will touch every industry,
whatever we're doing.
But as my son, as well, I
want him to be very inviting
and help change that environment
and just make it more open.
I think the next
generation is actually
going to be very awesome.
I think there's a lot of
change in that right now,
but I think that
next generation's
going to be really cool to bring
up-- have that open next year.